russischen außenministerium also in
außenministerien der russischen
föderation und da kommen annalena
baerbock und sergey lavrov
die beiden amtskollegen nach einem
ausführlichen gespräch
das ist eingelöst worden und jetzt rein
telefonie haben bereits telefoniert aber
diese persönliches treffen ist und wir
hoffen dass im ergebnis wie ein
interessierte und konstruktive
zusammenarbeit
sie haben standhaft viele eine reihe von
aktuellen fragen
über die interessanten so gut
nachbarschaftlichen bisschen deutschland
tid sich gründen auf der hochachtung und
berücksichtigung der interessen
voreinander
ich dass ich interesse habe
zusammenarbeit mit der neuen regierung
der überwindung der entstandenen
probleme die es gibt dass viele solcher
sowohl im gegenseitigen bereich auch in
der zusammenarbeit mit den anderen
staaten es gibt ein dieses potenzial wir
haben bereits im letzten jahr vermerkt
dass der warenaustausch gestiegen ist im
letzten jahr verglichen mit 2009 10 und
wir gehen davon aus dass wir zusätzliche
anstrengungen unternehmen müssen sowohl
auf dazwischen staaten auch die mit den
entsprechenden begreifen um diese
positive dynamik fest zu
und es gibt solche
kooperationsvorhaben in solchen
perspektiven bereichen wie
gesundheitswesen klimawechsel
erneuerbare energien und auch
wasserstoff strategien
sie hatten die meinungen ausgetauscht in
frage
mit der fortsetzung des prozesses sehr
setzte verzierung und
inbetriebnahme des
gasleitung nord stream das ist ein
wichtiges projekt was gerichtet auf die
sicherung deutschland und ganz europa
mit energie wir haben die deutschen
kollegen darauf hingewiesen dass dieses
projekt politisiert wird es gibt diese
versuche wir haben auch
besprochen
[Musik]
wir sind sicher dass die deutschen
massenmedien in russland und die
russischen und deutschland gleich
berechtigt ohne diskriminierung arbeiten
müssen sie haben uns ausgesprochen für
die wiederaufnahme der tätigkeit des
petersburger dialogs es ist erfreulich
dass die meisten teilnehmer seitens
deutschland und russland sich für die
fortführung dieses projektes
ausgesprochen haben wir haben noch ein
forum unterstützt potsdamer burg treffen
wir haben die meinungen ausgetauscht
über die aktuellen internationalen
fragen sind auch über die beziehungen
zwischen der russischen föderation und
der europäischen union in vieler
hinsicht bleiben diese beziehungen geist
der anti russische linien in brüssel und
eine gruppe der
länder wir haben unser sorge zum westen
gebracht über senator kurs und wir haben
ziemlich ausführlich besprochen die
initiativen die die russische seite
vorgelegt hat in bezug auf die
auf die vereinbarung von sachlichen
juristischen und die sicherheits
wichtigen garantien ich rufe in der
innung solcher garantien wurden von uns
an die vereinigten staaten von amerika
und auch an die mitglieder des nord
wir warten jetzt die antwort darauf und
die verhandlungen fortzuführen
über die ukraine haben wir gemeinsame
verständnis dass alternativlos ist eine
reihe von maßnahmen minsk und wir haben
wir wollen diese versuche haben
widerlegt die russische föderation als
eine seite des konfliktes darzustellen
und die der russland die fehlenden
fortschritte bei der umsetzung von
münster vereinbarung zu schieben wir
hoffen dass die deutschen kollegen ihre
partner beeinflussen werden damit sie
endlich mal die übernommenen
verpflichtungen erfüllen in diesem
kontext haben wir auch die meinungen
ausgetauscht über die weitere
perspektive der zusammenarbeit im rahmen
des normandie formats und darüber welche
schritte unternehmen werden müssen damit
diese vierergruppe dazu beiträgt das
minsker maßnahmen komplexe umgesetzt
wird in erster linie im rahmen der
kontaktgruppe war sowohl aktiv als auch
donetsk und lugansk vertreten sind wir
haben auch gesprochen über die situation
an der viola russisch polnischen grenze
wir hoffen dass alle interessierten
parteien die sich bemühen werden um
diesen konflikt zu lösen durch den
dialog mit den mit der regierung von bis
wir haben auch versprochen über die
friedensstiftende
maßnahmen von der kws zur stabilisierung
der situation in kasachstan und auch in
anderen fragen haben wir mit deutschland
aufgebaut ein dialog in einer ganzen
reihe von ausrichtungen einschließlich
auch der situation im nahen osten in
nordafrika russland hat aktiv sich
freilich an der konferenz die im rahmen
der regulierung von libyen in berlin und
paris sich beteiligt das und jetzt haben
wir interesse dass möglichst schnell
auch die
vereinbarten die vereinbarungen
umgesetzt werden und wie wir gesagt
haben wir sind bereit eine zusätzliche
information zu liefern über die
mühen die unternommen werden zu
endgültigen politischen regelung der
situation in syrien regelungs der
humanitären probleme und auch der
wirtschaftliche dieser stellung der
syrischen republik wir arbeiten mit
deutschland auch aktiv zusammen bei der
schaffung von bedingungen sind bei der
wiederaufnahme der aktionsplan bei der
regelung der situation um das
atomprogramm von iran wir haben auch
eine solche wichtiges thema die
afghanistan insgesamt sehen wir haben
wir die gleiche herangehensweise über
die grundsätzlichen fragen bei der
agenda von afghanistan das betrifft die
unterbindung der bedrohung der
verbreitung von
terrorismus und nach business und auch
die anstellung der
migrationsströmen und auch die leistung
der humanitären unterstützung an die
bevölkerung wir haben ein gemeinsames
interesse mit deutschen dass die
situation auf dem balkan im balkan
positiv sich weiterentwickelt wir
genauso wie auch deutschland sind
mitglieder des
lenkungsausschusses in bosnien und
herzegowina
im rahmen der vereinbarung von diäten
und wir haben interesse dass prozess des
konzerns im rahmen der tätigkeit dieses
wichtigen mechanismus
insgesamt war die diskussion
nutzen es wurden natürlich all die
fragen besprochen die bis jetzt
gegenstand der verschiedenen meinungen
angeht aber der meinungsaustausch hat
demonstriert dass wir langsam nach vorne
uns bewegen können diese
meinungsverschiedenheit überwinden zum
sonsten und zum nutzer unserer völker
und zum gunsten all die aufgaben die vor
der internationalen gemeinschaft sehen
bei verschiedenen punkten der welt ich
bin dankbar sehr ministerin und auch der
gesamten delegation für die gemeinsame
arbeit danke
schwing und tag auch von meiner seite
lieber kollege herzlichen dank für die
einladung für die gastfreundschaft heute
hier in moskau sein zu können mir war
wichtig schnell nach antritt der neuen
bundesregierung hierher zu kommen ich
bin mit einer dicken gesprächs mappe
gekommen sie ist dick weil es eine ganze
reihe von themen zu besprechen gibt in
denen wir große teils fundamentale
meinungsverschiedenheiten
haben sie ist aber auch so dick weil es
so viele themen gibt bei dem wir chancen
für mehr zusammenarbeit sehen russland
und deutschland spielen beide eine
wichtige rolle in unserem gemeinsamen
europäischen haus wir leben seit über 75
jahren in frieden zusammen wir haben ein
fundamentales interesse an stabilen
beziehungen
deutschland ist eine handels nation wir
leben vom austausch 14.000 junge
russinnen und russen studieren derzeit
in deutschland so viele wie in keinem
anderen land
wir profitieren enorm von den über 1000
hochschulkooperationen die es zwischen
unserer beiden länder gibt und wir
freuen uns dass in russland mehr
menschen deutsch lernen als irgendwo
sonst auf der welt nämlich über
360.000 das zeigt wie sich unser
gemeinsames potenzial in wissenschaft
und kultur ist auch wenn wir beim
petersburger dialog noch auseinander
sind gerade auch mit blick auf die
listung von deutschen andrews
zusammen mit russlands haben wir die
wiener nuklear vereinbarung zustande
gebracht und nur mit russland werden wir
sie wiederbeleben können dafür brauchen
wir jetzt dringende fortschritte in den
verhandlungen
denn die zeit um das abkommen zu retten
sie schwindet
wir haben jedes interesse auch an
russlands riesigen potenzial bei
erneuerbaren energien dass wir dort
gemeinsam zusammenarbeiten um den
nachhaltigen umbau unserer beiden
wirtschaften gemeinsam zu schaffen denn
ohne das größte land welt werden wir die
klimakrise nicht bewältigen können in
russland könnte allein durch die
aufforstung von brachflächen der
dreifache co2 ausstoß deutschlands
gebunden werden das zeigt wie wahnsinnig
groß das potenzial mit blick auf
aufforstung und co2 bindung ist aber wir
brauchen auch ein verlässliches russland
um europa in den nächsten jahren als
übergang weiterhin mit gas versorgen zu
können dass wir noch für einige jahre
brauchen werden zugleich und ich hatte
gestern ja auch gespräche hier vor ort
zum thema energie zeigt sich wie
wahnsinnig groß das potenzial in
russland für wasserstoff gerade auch für
grünen wasserstoff ist und in diesem
bereich müssen wir schon allein um
weltweit die klimakrise in den griff zu
bekommen
gemeinsam zusammenarbeiten und das thema
energie ist sicher 1 wo wir eine
vertiefte zusammenarbeit gerade auch mit
blick auf nachhaltigkeit gemeinsam auf
den weg bringen könnten
über viele dieser themen die ihnen auch
angesprochen worden sind haben wir
gemeinsam gesprochen aber gerade weil
deutschland wie kaum ein anderes land
vom handel wissenschaft und austausch
lebt haben wir ein noch fundamentales
interesse
am erhalt der europäischen
friedensordnung in der für alle gleiche
und verbindliche regeln gelten und auf
die sich alle verlassen können
denn es wird keine sicherheits in
unserem gemeinsamen haus europas geben
wenn es nicht gemeinsame regeln gibt auf
die sich alle immer wieder beziehen und
verlassen können sei es beim austausch
von wirtschaft sei es beim austausch von
kultur sei es bei freundschaften sei es
bei familien oder auch beim austausch
unserer beiden länder
und diese gemeinsam regeln sind das
fundament unseres gemeinsamen
europäischen hauses für deutschland sind
sie unsere existenzgrundlage und deshalb
haben wir keine andere wahl als unsere
gemeinsamen regeln zu verteidigen auch
wenn es einen hohen zum teil
wirtschaftlichen preis zu diesem
gemeinsamen regeln gehört die
europäische menschenrechtskonvention in
der sich alle staaten verpflichtet haben
entscheidungen des europäischen
gerichtshof für menschenrechte zu
befolgen wir denken dabei auch an den
fallenden und an memorial
vor allem gehört dazu war auch die
un-charta sowie die schlussakte von
helsinki und die charta von paris in
denen alle staaten auch unsere beiden
länder sich gemeinsam verpflichtet haben
einander nicht mit gewalt anwendungen zu
drohen
in den letzten wochen haben sich mehr
als hundert tausend russische soldaten
mit panzern und geschützen der nähe der
ukraine versammelt ohne
nachvollziehbaren grund und es ist
schwer das nicht als drohung zu
verstehen
seit meinem amtsantritt dreht sich ein
großteil meiner gespräche deshalb nicht
um die frage wie wir mit russland
gemeinsam kooperieren können wie wir die
zusammenarbeit weiter vertiefen können
sondern welche maßnahmen wir als eu als
g7 und nato mit blick auf die russische
situation gemeinsam treffen können wenn
sie ihre drohung mit gewalt war machen
sollte
diese situation haben wir uns als
bundesregierung nicht ausgesucht aber
wir können und werden ihr auch nicht aus
dem weg gehen
russland hat sicherheits garantien
gefordert es wurde eben auch noch mal
deutlich wir sind bereit zu einem
ernsthaften dialog über gegenseitige
vereinbarung und schritte die allen in
europa mehr sicherheit bringen
sicherheit für die menschen in riga
sicherheit für die menschen in bukarest
sicherheit für die menschen in berlin
sicherheit für die menschen in sankt
petersburg
wir haben auch schon begonnen zu
diskutieren wie solche schritte zu mehr
gemeinsamer sicherheit aussehen könnten
die gespräche der osze und im
nato-russland-rat waren aus unserer
sicht ein erster sinnvoller schritt zu
einem solchen dialog dass dort in der
ersten sitzung seit
jahren eigentlich nicht den wenigen
stunden alle probleme gelöst wurden
konnten das konnte eigentlich niemanden
wirklich überraschen
jetzt ist es aus unserer sicht wichtig
den normandie prozess wieder mit leben
zu füllen um endlich bei der
implementierung der minsker vereinbarung
voranzukommen
das wäre ein großer schritt für mehr
sicherheit in europa ein schritt für
sicherheit für uns alle ich habe gestern
in kiew und heute hier in moskau eben
schritte dazu diskutiert wir haben
vorschläge gegenseitig erwogen und
miteinander besprochen wie wir den
prozess auf allen ebenen wieder in gang
setzen können und es ist gut dass alle
zudem normandie format und zu den
minsker vereinbarungen sich bekannt
haben und dass wir ein gemeinsames
stände verständnis auch heute hier haben
auf basis der minsker vereinbarung im
normandie format weiter zu arbeiten und
dafür ein entsprechendes gemeinsames
treffen vorbereiten zu können
sehr geehrter kollege lawrow vor unserem
treffen habe ich im namen der
bundesregierung und dem namen meiner
landsleute dem grab des unbekannten
soldaten unseren respekt bezeugt
dort als deutsche außenministerin zu
stehen erfüllt mich mit charme und
ehrfurcht nichts kann das ausmaß des
leids und der zerstörung die wir
deutschen über die völker der
sowjetunion gebracht haben aufwiegen
und selbst nach in teilen schwierigen
gesprächen wie wir sie heute führen
steht überall meine unsere demut und die
dankbarkeit für die bereitschaft der
menschen in russland zur versöhnung
wir die wir politische verantwortung
tragen haben keine wichtigere pflicht
als unsere bevölkerung zu schützen
vor allen dingen vor krieg und gewalt
ich bin überzeugt das können wir am
besten durch erfolgreiche gespräche
erreichen nicht gegen einander sondern
miteinander
und deswegen hoffe ich dass heute der
anfang eines regnen offenen und
ehrlichen austausches war so wie es sich
zwischen unseren beiden ländern gehört
herzlichen dank
wir kommen nun zu den fragen eine frage
von derzeit
guten tag und vielen dank eine frage an
sie beide
deutschland hat in der eu seit vielen
jahren eine sonderrolle gespielt was den
dialog mit russland angeht in keiner
mehr mit russland sprechen konnte konnte
es deutschland noch und wurde dafür auch
oft kritisiert sehen sie für die neue
bundesregierung eine ähnliche
sonderrolle was den dialog mit russland
innerhalb europas angeht
und an sie gerichtet herr außenminister
lawrow in deutschland betont sehr die
bereitschaft zum dialog droht aber auch
mit schwerwiegenden konsequenzen in
russland den konflikt an der
ukrainischen grenze weiter eskalieren
sollte
was sind die schärfsten konsequenzen mit
denen die bundesregierung russland
gedroht hat bislang und waren diese
konsequenzen auch in dem gespräch heute
thema vielen dank
dialog ist dann nur erfolgreich wenn
alle gemeinsam an einem tisch sitzen und
deswegen ist es mir so wichtig
mit meinen partnerinnen und partnern in
der europäischen union aber der nato
auch im rahmen der g7 alles dafür zu tun
dass wir gemeinsam in dieser situation
zum gesprächstisch zurückkehren und ja
ich als deutsche außenministerin möchte
dafür meinen beitrag leisten
deswegen habe ich wie gesagt in den
letzten monaten eigentlich fast nichts
anderes gemacht als mit blick auf die
deeskalation in dieser situation viele
viele gespräche zu führen und deswegen
war ich gestern den kirchen bin heute
hier in moskau und wir werden das
gespräch jetzt ja auch noch fortführen
genau in dem sinne wie man gerade im
rahmen des normandie formates wieder an
den verhandlungstisch zurück kommt
ich habe nicht ganz verstanden die frage
sie haben gesagt dass deutschland
russland gehört angedroht hat und welche
folgen von diesen druck und kommen oder
bitte holen sie ihre frage nochmals
sehr gerne deutschland betont in allen
gesprächen einen formaten die
bereitschaft zum dialog mit russland
sagt aber auch das schwerwiegende
konsequenzen drohen wenn russland in
konflikt mit der ukraine weiter
eskalieren sollte meine frage ist was
sind die schärfsten konsequenzen mit
denen die bundesregierung
russland droht und gibt es gab es waren
diese konsequenzen in ihrem gespräch
heute mit der außenministerin auch thema
wir hatten ausführlich gesprochen
darüber was in der tat stattfindet in
der ukraine und um die ukraine und vor
allem was
vor allem was geschieht mit der sabotage
im rahmen des kiewer regimes in bezug
auf die minsker vereinbarungen und auf
der grundlage des textes der minsker
vereinbarungen haben wir demonstriert
dass es notwendig ist diese sabotage so
aufzuhören und wir haben in der
absoluten genauer konsequenz wie in
diesem dokument festgeschrieben sollen
wir handeln dort steht alles klar dort
gibt es keine doppelte dreifache
deutungen
gibt wir haben auch erklärt dass die
eskalation die jetzt aus dem mund vieler
westlichen politikern klingt und dabei
wird gemeint eben dass die präsenz
unserer eigenen streitkräfte in unserem
eigenen hoheitsgebiet und die
durchführung von notwendigen
militärischen vorbereitung
damit beschäftigt sich ja jedes land und
wir haben erklärt wir können
irgendwelche forderungen empfangen was
sie aktionen unserer eigenen
streitkräfte in unserem eigenen land
angeht übrigens wir haben darauf
hingewiesen dass bei der aufstellung von
forderungen dass unsere streitkräfte
zurück in die kasernen gefordert werden
würde so machten die amerikaner und
sogleich erklären sie nahte mit mensa
das was im nato territorium angeht die
bewegung in der drogen einschließlich
der truppen die aus dem ozean befördert
wurde das betreffe nur sozusagen die
nato-länder wir sehen ja die doppelt der
standard was die folgen angeht was womit
uns deutschland trotz so kann ich nicht
welche schritte die deutsche regierung
den unternehmen wird
situation wir werden keine zusammen wir
haben keine zur vorwände liefern und
wird auch keine liefern um eine solche
situation zu schaffen wir verlangen nur
eins dass das was vereinbart wurde ganz
deutlich so ausgeführt wird das betrifft
sowohl die missgriff einfach nur die wie
gesagt von der ukrainische regime
sabotiert werden wie auch die sicherheit
ihren europa die vorschläge die wir
eingebracht haben zu untersuchung von
usa und der nordatlantischen allianz die
gründen sich auf dem festen boden der
dokumente die auf der höchsten ebene
verabschiedet wurde einschließlich gibt
instanz
1999 wie auch in austin im jahre 2000
ja in der tat jedes land hat das recht
die eigenen land für sich zu suchen aber
anders es wurde gesagt dass jedes land
soll die eigene sicherheit so absichern
dass kein anderes land geben es
gefährdet wird und wir haben unsere
deutschen kollegen gebeten genauso wie
auch die amerikanischen kollegen zu
erklären wie wollen sie diesen konkreten
teil des verpflichtungen in der praxis
erleben wir hoffen dass dieses gespräch
fortgesetzt wird das dass das eine ganz
ernsthafte sache ist und wir können
nicht in die länge ziehen mit der
verabschiedung von konkreten
vereinbarungen das heißt wir bedrohen
keine mit gar nicht abel wir vernehmen
drohen in unsere richtung wir hoffen
dass das alles nur irgend welche
emotionen zu zeigen
die bestimmte kräfte in lagern der
westlichen
in bewegung setzen wir werden uns durch
konkrete schritte durch konkrete taten
leiten lassen unabhängig davon welche
konkreten schritte unser
partnerunternehmen so werden wir
natürlich auch unsere schritte bestimmen
und eine frage an frau baerbock
seitens der
vertreter der neuen bundesregierung
erklingen immer weitere stimmen zur nord
stream 2 es gibt aber immer wieder über
die ukraine
andere vertreter der bundesregierung
sagen jedoch ist ist ein geopolitisches
projekte man spricht auch von neuen
sanktionen
dennoch möchte ich sie fragen gibt es
denn eines konsolidierte meinung seitens
der bundesregierung vielen dank
ja und dies vereinbart in unserem
gemeinsamen koalitionsvertrag der neuen
deutschen bundesregierung in der wir
deutlich machen
dass für infrastrukturprojekte
und das gilt für alle energie
infrastrukturprojekte
dazu zählt auch nord stream 2 natürlich
das europäische energie rechts gilt und
zwar im buchstaben wie im geiste und
deswegen ist zurzeit auch das
zertifizierungsverfahren mit blick auf
diese pipeline ausgesetzt und zugleich
haben wir immer wieder bekräftigt auf
unterschiedlichen ebenen dieser
bundesregierung dass solche energie als
waffe eingesetzt werden dass das dann
auch entsprechende auswirkungen mit
blick auf diese pipeline hätte
bei chance drehte die nächste frage von
reuters vielen dank alexander hass von
reuters eine frage an sie beide frau
ministerin werber und herr minister
lawrow nach ihrem gespräch heute wie
wahrscheinlich ist es dass das nochmal
die von formaten weiter auf
außenministerebene wieder zusammenkommt
können sie dann zeithorizont skizzieren
und angesichts der globalen ausrichtung
bzw des konflikts wäre es nicht sinnvoll
auch die usa an dem format zu beteiligen
wir sind ja mitten noch in unserem
ersten persönlichen arbeitstreffen hier
werden viele der fragen die wir gerade
an gerissen haben auch weiter jetzt
während des mittagessens noch weiter
diskutieren sie haben ja vielleicht auch
herausgehört dass wir auch mit blick auf
die faktenlage vor ort sowohl mit blick
auf die umsetzung des münchner abkommens
unterschiedliche sichtweisen nach wie
vor haben aber deswegen ist es so
wichtig dass die gespräche weitergeführt
werden da das minsker abkommen im namen
des normandie formates jahr verhandelt
vereinbart worden ist ist es deswegen
auch wichtig dass wir im normativ format
zurück an den verhandlungstisch kommen
und wir beide als außenminister werden
und dass es ein zwischenstand unserer
gespräche alles dafür tun dass wir jetzt
die schritte dafür schnellstmöglich
einleiten können
das schulden wir ja unser position ist
gut bekannt für uns ist das wichtigste
nicht wann wir uns treffen sonne wofür
wir uns treffen wenn wir uns treffen
damit präsidentiellen ski wieder sagen
darf dass auf seine initiative eine
gruppe der verehrten
leiter zusammen gekommen ist und dabei
hält er seine mission für abgeschlossen
das brauchen wir in paris sie haben
darüber auch gesprochen
2009/10 fanden gipfeltreffen allein sie
format 4 wohin keinesfalls leichten
verhandlungen von allen teilnehmer
dieses gipfels formuliert und bestätigt
wurden konkrete schritte die in erster
linie die tiere macht unternommen soll
bis sie es wurde nichts in dieser
hinsicht gemacht es ist eine ganze reihe
von beispielen bekannt als die
ukrainische seite die
feuereinstellung
sabotiert hat das was wir bereits 2019
verabschiedet haben das heißt wir müssen
wohl genau verstehen womit wir zu einem
treffen im normandie format in der der
anderen ebene hingehen dass eine solche
arbeit wird jetzt unternommen im rahmen
der
außenpolitischen berater der führer des
normandie formats unsere ansätze sind
ganz klar offen und begründet und wir
rechnen damit dass die mehrfache
wiederholung dieser ansätze die in
berlin und in paris gehört wurde dann
ein tier hoffen wir nicht wir hoffen nur
dass berlin und paris herrn vilimsky
dazu zwingen dass er das eben erfüllt
was er mehrfach fast 400 auszuführen und
wir uns wie herr präsident putin
mehrfach betont hat als mitglied der
kontaktgruppe als mitglieder des
normalen die hamas dazu beitragen dass
die günstigen bedingungen zur erreichung
der vereinbarungen
geschaffen werden also vereinfachung und
wie wir in der praxis minsker komplex
des friedens umgesetzt werden müssen wir
haben interesse daran auf richtig
interessiert was die vereinigten staaten
angeht so haben wir das auch mehrfach
besprochen bei der
vorausgegangene administration von
donald trump gab es in washington ein
sondern vertrete der dass der
unterstützte die ukrainische regelung
seine bemühungen liefen parallel zum
normandie format und parallel zur
sitzungen der kontaktgruppe er hatte
spezifische ansichten darauf wer und was
zu tun hat die ansichten die ihren
ehrlich gesagt dem inhalt des minsker
komplexes friedens widersprachen aber
ich habe bereits das besprochen zum
jetzigen zeit gehen wir davon aus dass
die jetzige administration amerikanische
realistische die situation und die
ukrainische regierung betrachtet und
erkennt an die notwendigkeit der lösung
in erster linie des problems des
sonderstatus von john bass ich
versichere sie wenn die klarheit in
diese er sich erschaffen wird ich meine
auch das sind was sie vollmachten angeht
die vollmachten die donetsk und ganz
erhalten müssen im rahmen des minsker
der minsker verhandlungen werden alle
anderen fragen leichter zu lösen jetzt
stößt sich alles an den
offensichtliche und in der gesetzgebung
festgelder die politische aspekte der
minister vereinbarung nur im quatschen
untergehen zu lassen und die diskussion
in die richtung von wichtigen aber nicht
zu richten wir werden die vereinigten
staaten unterstützen wenn sie im rahmen
der existierenden format uns helfen
werden in diese richtung uns zu bewegen
denn das hat das wichtige einfluss auf
den cash
ich habe zwei fragen zum einen anfang
einer lena berbalk
frau berbalk sie wissen dass deutsche
journalisten in deutschland das eher
schwer haben sie sind massiven druck
ausgesetzt massiver diskriminierung die
deutsche regulierungsbehörde hat nun
beschlossen dass sie nicht beschlossen
aber setzten den wunsch bereits geäußert
dass er herr cdrc nicht in deutschland
senden wird und dass trotzdem dass das
internationale recht auf unserer seite
ist hier sind in übereinstimmung mit der
europäischen konvention über über
grenzüberschreitendes fernsehen der auch
deutschland unterliegt
und nichtsdestotrotz
haben wir diese probleme
mit dem deutschen journalisten-verband
erfahren dass er sie blockiert wird in
deutschland wir können das rad also kaum
fortsetzen und das obwohl er viele
internationale auszeichnungen bekommen
hat wie auch die emmy awards nirgendwo
haben wir so schwer wie in deutschland
und die regierung sagt dass sie nichts
damit zu tun hat auf der anderen seite
gibt es zum beispiel die europäische
menschenrechtskonvention sie besagt dass
regierungen dafür zuständig sind das
dass der zugang zur freien information
zur
meinungspluralität gegeben ist das haben
wir momentan nicht dass ihn wenn nicht
können wir also davon ausgehen dass wir
bei unserer weiteren übertragung in
deutschland rückendeckung von der
deutschen regierung haben werden
deutschland produziert seit jahren in
deutschland sendet über das internet der
sender gibt selbst an dass man der
viertgrößte nachrichtenkanal im bereich
der sozialen medien ist es gibt
jederzeit ungehinderten zugang zur
journalistischen tätigkeit zudem
bundespressekonferenz
russia today immer präsent bei fast
jeder demonstration ist russia today
präsent und das ist da staatliche
einmischung gibt das ist nicht der fall
sondern wir haben eine entscheidung mit
blick auf die plattform die getroffen
ist von den plattformen inhaber youtube
mit blick auf falschinformationen
weil man gegen die nutzungsregeln
verstoßen hat damit hat die deutsche
bundesregierung nichts zu tun und eine
einmischung der deutschen
bundesregierung würde auch unser
deutschen verfassung widersprechen
das finde ich das geläster was das cover
wasserburg
dank es ist nun mal so so hat es frau
beerbach gesagt dass die deutsche
regierung unmöglich da unterstützung
leisten kann vielleicht können wir uns
ja auf die unterstützung des russischen
außenministeriums das kann man nicht nur
zu erwarten können es wird jetzt auch
umgesetzt und wir haben heute ziemlich
ausführlich zum wievielten mal
gesprochen denn in wirklichkeit in der
frühesten phase diese nicht schön
situation habe ich den botschafter der
bundesrepublik deutschland eingeladen
und wir haben auch auf anderen ebenen
diese gespräche geführt wir sind
natürlich besorgt
dafür darum was mit unseren journalisten
passiert wir gehen davon aus dass die
deutsche regierung eine bestimmten bezug
zu dem was geschieht hat ich möchte in
erinnerung rufen dass in der frühesten
phase im grunde genommen die banken
bedingung unser journalisten eingestellt
wurde dann wurde das wieder aufgestellt
und es entstanden manche merkmale für
optimismus und dann gab es immer weniger
solche merkmale für optimismus und eben
gerade die deutschen
macht war nicht bereich eine lizenz für
russia today deutschland so
auszufertigen und als sascha today
deutschland sich an andere länder warnte
dann hat eben wie ich bin sicher berlin
gerade berlin alles unternommen hat
damit diese entscheidung auch in anderen
hauptstädten nicht durchgeführte
letztendlich wurde das von serbien
gemacht und obwohl alle genehmigungen
entsprechend der europäischen
konvention über
grenzüberschreitende fernsehen
abgefertigt hat der deutsche regulator
diese sputnik übertragung blockiert und
wir sind der meinung dass das sich
einmischung in die tätigkeit der
unabhängige journalisten das
widerspricht nicht nur der europäischen
konvention über die
grenzüberschreitende nachrichten ist
sondern auch den grenzüberschreitenden
konvention von ionesco vereinbarungen
bei der us der über die nichtzulassung
hindernisse zu schaffen beim zugang zu
information und natürlich wir gehen
davon aus dass deutschland als
teilnehmer dieser internationalen
verträge und vereinbarungen doch
maßnahmen treffen wird die den kanal
russia today deutschland nicht
diskriminieren werden wir wünschen uns
dass da die genehmigung erhalten wird
wir haben kein interesse
irgendwie spiegelbildlich dazu
verhandeln aber im herzigen augenblick
rechnen wir mit konkrete handlungen
seitens unsere deutschen partner
ich werde auch nicht nennen welche
handlungen es unternommen werden das
wichtigste ist dass die russische
journalistin sich komfortabel fühlen und
nicht diskriminiert fühlen und wenn wir
von unseren journalisten eben solche
bewertung der entstandene situation dann
wird das ein scheiß alles auch
gelöst ich betone nochmals wir wollen
keine hindernisse zu schaffen auf dem
wege der durchführung der professionelle
tätigkeit der deutschen journalisten in
der russischen föderation
aber wenn es notwendig sein wird werden
wir bemüht sich sein egal wenn wir das
vermeiden wollen müssen wir doch
contra maßnahmen zu treffen solche
situationen haben wir
zum schluss
hier etwas lustigeres zum schluss bitter
dank folgende frage sehr kurz
nochmal zu russia today frau berbalk wir
würden gerne ihre aufmerksamkeit darauf
lenken wie schwierig sich die situation
gestaltet wenn man diese frage
politisiert
ich spreche im rahmen des
journalistenverbandes in russland wir
haben uns auch offiziell an sünden wand
und wir nutzen nun die möglichkeit um
dieses papier zu übergeben wir hoffen
sehr dass sie da rein schauen und dass
sie reagieren werden ich hoffe dass sie
dafür die zeit aufbringen können vielen
dank
ich kann noch mal unterstreichen dass
bei uns die fresse pressefreiheit
bedeutet dass es keine staatliche
einmischung in dem bereich gibt wir
haben eine klare verfassung die in
deutschland verbietet dass es einen
staatlichen rundfunk gibt egal ob der
staat deutschland usa oder russland
heißt und auf dieser grundlage wird bei
uns in deutschland auch mit blick auf
die zuständigen behörden das verfahren
so was sie will
annalena baerbock die deutsche
außenministerin auf ihrer ersten großen
sehr brisanten reise nach russland in
moskau zusammengetroffen mit ihrem
amtskollegen sergei lavrov ich grüße sie
ganz herzlich meine damen und herren aus
dem studio und ich begrüße ganz herzlich
professor heinemann bruder unser experte
für das was da gerade alles passiert und
was das hinterland betrifft sie haben
alles mitverfolgt und sind erstaunt über
die vielen themen und über die vielen
einigungen und un- einigung
insgesamt ist die gute botschaft das
sehr
deeskaliert reagiert also gesprochen
wurde beide haben eigentlich
signalisiert
am anfang die gemeinsamkeiten also
wandel durch handel das war praktisch
der gleiche tenor sowohl bei berbalk wie
bei wie bei lahr wolf
sie haben auch kritische themen
angestrebt was man auch bei dem bei dem
gemeinsamkeiten verbinden verbinden denn
im grunde gehört das muss man doch
machen man kann noch nicht sofort mit
dem messer los stürzen bei solchen
pressekonferenzen nach solchen
bilateralen gesprächen oder nein wenn
man sich jetzt die letzten wochen
anguckt und dass seine rhetorische säbel
rasseln und und die verunsicherung
darüber ob es einen krieg zwischen
russland und der ukraine gibt und wie
die nato darauf reagieren wird dann war
dieses thema weitaus weniger prominent
hierüber beiden als man es hätte
erwarten können und insofern ist das
erstmal ein entspannungssignal das ist
schon mal gut und dialog ist er ohnehin
das was man sich vorgenommen hat und
diplomatie nun sind da zwei
spitzendiplomaten der eines ganz lange
im dienst die andere ist noch sehr
kurzem dienst und es wurde überall in
der presse geschrieben es ist ihre große
erste bewährungsprobe würden sie das
auch so sehen als bewährungsprobe und
wenn wie ist ihr ausgegangen bisher
also im verhältnis zu dem auftritt vor
den gesprächen wo sie sichtbar nervös
angespannt und unsicher war ist sie nach
diesen zweieinhalb stunden mit lover bei
der pressekonferenz
wesentlich souveräner aufgetreten sie
hat auch die positionen finde ich sehr
also souverän vorgetragen man hat ja
jetzt nicht den eindruck dass sie
irgendwie von lahm wurde aus ihrem
konzept gebracht worden ist insofern
würde ich sagen sie hat den stresstest
bestanden
es gibt aber auch eben dass viele
thematische ich will gar nicht sagen das
kleingedruckte das sind alles groß
gedruckte dinge die da an stehen die von
deutscher seite reklamiert wurden also
nicht nur das gemeinsame sondern auch
das fordernde oder dass vielleicht
manchmal auch herausfordernde dass auf
deutscher seite genannte was ist da bei
ihnen besonders aufgefallen
also sind er auch fühler ausgestreckt
wurden wir wollen eigentlich zu einem
dialog situation vielleicht wort wurde
zwar nicht erwähnt aber zu den zeiten
von schröder wieder zurückkehren also
petersburger dialog ja sowohl live als
auch baerbock kann sich dafür
ausgesprochen habe meinte ja aber da
müssten also die als extremistisch oder
ausländische agenten gelisteten
organisationen dann auch wieder
teilnehmen können möglicherweise kommt
man sich darauf wieder hingegen einige
haben gesagt worüber soll da eigentlich
noch dialog mit putin oder dem
russischen regime stattfinden da ist man
durchaus offen
in bezug auf die thematik
menschenrechten derweil nicht mehr moral
europäischer gerichtshof für
menschenrechte das wurde angesprochen
aber live hat dann quasi sofort die
einschränkung der pressefreiheit
gegenüber russia today in deutschland
angesprochen also da gab es so eine art
von ausgleichender schlagabtausch ihr
habt eure sorgen aber wir haben ja auch
und zu sorgen aber man hat das jetzt
auch nicht so zugespitzt dass man gesagt
hat also dass während die konditionen
unter denen wir da überhaupt noch weiter
verhandeln es klang ein bisschen so als
beklagte sich die russische seite in
person des außenministers sei worauf
natürlich vertreten über so manche
unzulänglichkeit nicht nenne es mal so
oder über dinge auf die russland lange
wartet dass sie vom westen eingelöst
werden versprechen hat er sogar gesagt
langhoff erwartet seit jahren dass
frankreich und deutschland auf die
ukraine druck ausüben die minsker
vereinbarungen umzusetzen zu deutsch das
ist ein sonderstatus des don bass
innerhalb des staatsmannes der ukraine
gibt im grunde genommen hat der damalige
ukrainische präsident poroschenko das
unterschrieben weil er mit dem rücken an
der wand stand weil sie in der bald
sowohl damals eingeschlossen waren und
weil es nur eine zielsetzung gab
beendigung der kampfhandlungen unter den
bedingungen haben wir das unterschrieben
heute will die ukraine das nicht mehr
ich frage mich auch ob sie eigentlich
den don was zurück wollen das heißt de
facto es ist so dass sie den pass
abgeschrieben haben die juden können sie
es aber nicht eingestehen dh deutschland
müsste die ukraine zu einer position
zwingen die sie formal nicht aufgeben
dieser war eigentlich gar nicht mehr
halten wollen aber die ist
unterschrieben haben werden die vorher
vorgängerregierung dass er letzten endes
man ist ja dann quasi weiterhin fragt ob
sie haben das unterschrieben natürlich
unter bedingungen und sagen okay
vorher müssen freie wahlen da
stattfinden und es muss kontrolle über
die russisch ukrainische grenze geben zu
deutsch abzug also man macht sich so
wechselseitig du musst den ersten
schritt machen und wenn du denen nicht
machst dann mache ich meinen schritten
ganz kurz noch wird nicht mehr so viel
zeit haben hoffen dass noch nato
erweiterung in richtung osten das ist
schon noch ein großes prettner es ist
interessant dass das thema sozusagen
verbal gar nicht angesprochen wurde
obwohl es sozusagen
vorher im vorfeld sehr sehr prominent
ausgeflaggt wurde aber dass gespräche
natürlich stattfinden können jetzt über
rüstungskontrolle über truppen
dislozierung darüber raketenabwehr
manöver gruppen beobachtungen usw also
dass wenn ja wenn da fortschritte
erzielt werden und man sozusagen die
russen wissen auch sie kriegen die
extrempositionen nicht durch aber wenn
man da vertrauensbildende maßnahmen
schafft dann wäre das ein gutes ergebnis
professor heinemann grüder ich danke
ihnen ganz herzlich für diese
einschätzungen auch wenn wir nicht alles
gehört haben am heutigen tag um was uns
gegangen sein mag
meine damen und herren es gibt eine neue
präsidentin des eu parlaments sie musste
jetzt gewählt werden weil der alte
präsident in diesem fall leider
verstorben ist ganz plötzlich davids das
soli nach diesem plötzlichen todesfall
war das parlament jetzt gezwungen diese
wahl auch schon etwas vorzuziehen als
die turnusgemäß anstand es gibt also es
gab eine sehr deutliche und klare
abstimmung
mit zone
458 stimmen
wir haben im gesamten das ist aber den
ersten wahlgang sofort eine absolute
mehrheit für die kandidaten roberta mit
toller sie hatte auch weil sie ist schon
als favoritin angetreten ist von den
christdemokraten in lagern wir haben
gerade den ersten blumenstrauß gesehen